we're taking a break from reporting on
movies that are breaking records and
doing smashing numbers I'm Dave and
welcome to your diverging gamespot news
update allegiant the third entry in the
shalane Woodley starring divergent
series open this weekend but it had a
tough run compared to the past two
movies Entertainment Weekly reports at
the film based on Veronica Roth's young
adult series made 29 point 1 million
domestically from Friday to Sunday which
is around half of what divergent made
when it debuted in 2014 2015's insurgent
took 50 2.3 million for its opening as
entertainment weekly points out drop
offs between franchise installments of
course are not unprecedented one recent
example was the final Hunger Games movie
which had the worst opening in franchise
history however the dip between catching
fire and mockingjay was around twenty
three percent while Allegiant fell by
almost half compared to insurgent this
isn't exactly encouraging for the final
divergent movie ascendant which comes
out june 2017 another element that could
be contributing to allegiance relatively
poor performance is that critics are not
exactly loving it the weekends winner
meanwhile was disney's animated movie
Zootopia which made 38 million dollars
this weekend it's now the top US movie
for three weeks running so what do you
think about the divergent series are you
a fan of the franchise let us know in
the comments section below or find me on
Twitter at a regular Dave and for all
your entertainment news stay tuned to
gamespot com